we are now finally sitting down with the
founder and curator of arc fusion Dave
videoing Duncan Thank You Alan yes and
yes this is an amazing we are at David's
radical wellness Summit and we've
mentioned it throughout our
conversations and David why don't you
give us the why are you so passionate
about this bringing all these brilliant
minds together and cracking this code
and bringing it to civilization
so basically I'm doing here at this
artesian summit what I do is a reporter
and it's sort of cool because normally
I'm writing it you know and as an
article or a book or something like that
but here I'm actually getting the people
alive and you know we curated it it's
pretty carefully curated to tell kind of
tell a story so we went from in the
morning to massive data you know all the
data you can collect about people health
data genetics all of that and then we
moved into AI and analytics so how do
you make sense of all that data yeah and
then we we went in the afternoon we
talked about policy at Jonathan Bush
talked about that we then went to the
business of radical wellness and then
finally like the futuristic stuff so
this was really the way it's all a story
yeah about all the stuff I get to write
about and it's so cool like these are
the these are people I quote from my
articles or I do stories about my George
Church yeah or David Sinclair I mean
many of the people who are on stage I've
written stories about you know for wired
or mighty tech review or New York Times
or something like that which was our
homework before the yes and that's a
very good homework well link those also
in the bio of the video really good
writing and like you said you tell the
story and that's so important to get
people inspired about it yeah you did
here as well you curated the event based
on that what do you think are some of
these some of the highlights from
today's event I don't know it's hard to
really pick because you know you invite
all these great people to come you don't
know what they're gonna say you know is
it gonna work or not
I can't really think of an any
presentation today
that didn't hit the mark I mean it was
amazing and I even you know a lot of
these people are accomplished speakers
they do a lot of talks yes and I kind of
give their like there can talk I made
them do a you know like an original talk
yes partly because they were very short
yes six minute or six minutes so we got
a lot of original thinking yeah from
people you know that I kind of provoked
basically yes and so that's that's kind
of the process I do as a journalist yeah
and you know learning about them and
getting them you know provoking them in
a way you know to get them to think
about stuff so I think we got some
amazing perspectives from people who are
really making this radical illness
happen on all different levels yep and
you're at the forefront of curating them
to get together and collaborate that's
why I love you because you're doing it
you're execute you were all right why
don't we plug your upcoming book well
yeah actually I'm working on a book on
robots talking to robots tales from our
human robot futures so these are
different scenarios at different robots
I mean there's like a cop bot there's a
driverless car bot there's a sexpot
there's a even a god but police spot
politician black quarterback bot mm-hmm
I mean we're wandering in this chapter
is is Brady actually a robot mm-hmm I
mean no human could actually really do
what he does so anyway that's what the
books about it's a lot of fun and it's
it's opening people up to all the future
possibilities of robots across all these
different facets so it's a mix of
interviews and kind of present-day
you know where we are with different
kinds of robots and it was sort of
getting a call so you know different
kinds of robots in the present but then
where it might go in the future and
when's the next arc fusion event
probably next show can we treat is like
once we do it in like six months maybe
before it snows here hey oh my god it's
like an August 8th